Let's talk about signs for a second. For real numbers, we have 3 different
cases. Every real number is either negative, 0, or positive. Now since
discriminants are made of real numbers, assuming that the coefficients of our
quadratic equation are real, then they had to fall into these 3 categories. Each
of these types of discriminants matches a certain number of roots Of a parabola,
or in other words, a certain number of solutions to our quadratic equation,
which we can of course find by our quadratic formula, using the disciminate. So
here are 3 types of discriminates, and which type do you think produces 2 real
roots, which type do you think produces 1 real root, and which type do you think
produces no real roots?